another player is entering the 2024
Republican primary its former Arkansas
governor ASA Hutchinson who will be
running against Donald Trump
Nikki Haley and vivec ramaswamy he
announced this when speaking to Jonathan
Carl from ABC not exactly making huge
headlines understandably but let's take
a listen when I spoke to you earlier
this year you said you were thinking
about running for president have you
made a decision are you running I have
made a decision and my decision is I'm
going to run for president of the United
States wow while the formal announcement
will be later in April Bentonville uh I
wanted to make that'll be a real party
clear that to you Jonathan I am going to
be running and the reason as I've
traveled the country for six months I
hear people talk about the leadership of
our country and I'm convinced that
people want leaders that appeal to the
best of America and not simply appeal to
our worst instincts I always find it
funny when they say they've traveled the
country and I know it's sort of like you
have to do it and you have to say it but
do you really need to travel the country
to figure out a lot of these things it's
always is a weird thing to hear and that
inspires me when I see everyday
Americans just saying give us good
leadership give us Common Sense
consistent conservatism and optimism
about our great country yeah and that
inspires me and I believe I can be that
kind of leader for the people of America
all right so he has absolutely no shot
but it is interesting to see more people
enter uh if I were a betting man and I'm
not my guess is Asa Hutchinson doesn't
even make it past the first Republican
primary now that being said more
candidates generally does seem to be
better for Donald Trump the more people
there are running the Republican primary
what we see in the polling is that it
helps Trump versus DeSantis we have some
new-ish polls I'm trying to look at ones
that are actually sort of like well well
rated there's a Trafalgar group poll
which is a right-leaning poll it's a
multi-way poll it has Trump over
DeSantis by 34 with Liz Cheney who
doesn't seem to have any plan to on at
10 percent
uh then we have an Insider Advantage
poll that's a B rated poll Trump over
DeSantis by 33 and then we have a B plus
rated yugov poll in this poll Trump does
better with more candidates this isn't
surprising this is what we've seen when
it is just Trump versus DeSantis Trump
leads by 26 and when it is Trump versus
a whole bunch of people Trump leads by
31 and we could go further but this is
sort of where we are right now so
interesting uh that ASA Hutchinson is
running I truly wonder you know when
when people like this run
are they sitting in a room where someone
is telling them you've got a shot at
winning because they obviously don't or
is it that they're sitting in a room and
advisors say you don't have a shot but
this might raise your public profile you
might get yourself on a debate stage and
then you can parlay that into being a
contributor to Fox News or something
like what is actually in their minds
when they decide to run what do they
think versus what is the reality of what
can come from it and what is the basis
on which they're making these these
decisions it's an interesting thing we
now have a four-way race in the
Republican primary with one of those
four candidates under indictment and
we're going to very closely follow the
direction that this goes